la formation du conseil des ministres
pourquoi at elle fermé les yeux et
décidé de les nommer carmen adam la
première ministre
alors merci monsieur le président je
voudrais d'abord vous dire que je
regrette tout ce qui vient de se passer
parce que je crois que daniel breton est
quelqu'un qui est un homme très engagé
un homme de causes au niveau de
l'environnement et je trouve triste ce
qui vient de se passer
il m'a remis effectivement ce matin sa
démission et je crois que c'était une
décision judicieuse maintenant la
question plus précise du chef de
l'opposition officielle
je peux l'assurer de d'un certain nombre
de choses d'abord une vérification de
sécurité a été faite par la sûreté du
québec
comme c'est le corps avant que quelque
personne que ce soit ne soit nommé comme
ministre au gouvernement
d'ailleurs c'est la même procédure qui
est suivi pour les personnes candidates
à la haute fonction publique les
éléments contenus dans le dossier qui
m'ont été remis à l'époque n'étaient pas
de nature à mon point de vue à
l'empêcher d'exercer ses fonctions
ministérielles
d'ailleurs dans certains cas c'étaient
des gestes posés il ya 24 ans sans qu'on
a droit ou pardon aussi dans notre
société
par ailleurs par ailleurs en ce qui a
trait aux loyers non payés
monsieur breton ne m'en avait pas
informé monsieur le président en lui un
complément terme ce chef de l'opposition
dans le dossier une suicidaire qui a été
révélé par différents médias
il ya quand même plusieurs comportements
difficiles cela déjà coloré
la version que prétendait pouvoir donner
le menez l'environnement à l'égard du
bape
la question est la première mini ce
sachant tout cela pourquoi at elle
décidé de les nommer pourquoi at elle
décidé de le couvrir
alors qu'elle aurait dû dire la vérité à
tous les québécois à ce moment là sur
château porcien souche à l'opposition on
ne peut pas la mettre en question la
parole
1depuis nous amène en chantier à la
première alors merci monsieur le
président de fait je vous dis à vous que
j'ai dit toute la vérité sur ce que je
savais en ce qui a trait à monsieur
breton
je ne regrette pas de l'avoir nommé
compte tenu du fait qu'une personne a
droit à l'erreur a droit au pardon
nous sommes dans une société une société
qui croit à la réhabilitation et
monsieur breton étonnantes très engagées
en matière d'environnement qui connaît
particulièrement bien connaissez
particulièrement bien ses dossiers
d'ailleurs je suis certain qu'il
continuera de représenter les gens de
sainte marie saint jacques avec toute la
fougue qu'on lui connaît
cependant la décision prise ce matin
n'apparaît la décision la plus terminant
judicieuse à prendre escale
principal fait des films aguerris
bonjour monsieur le président quand les
policiers nous annonce tolérance zéro
tous les citoyens du québec comprennent
bien le message 06 euros quand c'est le
premier ministre qui dit tolérance zéro
dans son discours de nomination du
conseil des ministres doit-on comprendre
une autre signification des propos
pourtant si claire et classant des
citoyens eux comprennent très bien
tolérance zéro dans les gérants jobat
tolérance zéro en intégrité tolérance
zéro dans le respect des lois et
règlements du québec et des individus
tolérance zéro pour des comportements
inappropriés tolérance zéro pour les
mauvais payeurs tolérance zéro pour les
fraudeurs d'assurance-emploi tolérance
zéro pour les mauvais locataires
oublient de payer leur loyer
ma question est la première vie nice
devant ces faits et non des allégations
votre tolérance était la géométrie
variable où avez vous votre propre
définition personnelle
monsieur l'erreur du gouvernement
drôle de question je comprends qu'on
l'ait fait lever lui parce que le chef
s'est pas levé effectivement mais vient
lui dire que il fait partie d'un parti
politique qui est totalement discrédité
en matière d'éthique malheureusement
pour lui le dernier à
premièrement sur les deux premières
manches premièrement sur les deux
premières manches et les deux joueurs
vont redresser en présence deuxièmement
j'ai pu tuer le leader de l'opposition
sur le président le l'article 79 est
très clair et vous voyez très bien que
le leader du gouvernement ne veut
absolument pas répondre à la question la
question et sérieux je me suis le
président est-ce que tolérance zéro de
côté c'est sur la question sur l'état du
vermont effectivement parlant tolérance
zéro j'ai hâte que le parti vert
s'applique cette médecine qu'ils nous
disent par exemple qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans le cadre b cia au niveau du
port d'ars et c'est elle le ce
gouvernement qui est en place au niveau
des garderies on y parlait plus loin du
parti libéral où était cette tolérance
zéro monsieur le président honni